[Música]
el canciller chileno Alberto van claver
en confirmó que un avión enviado por
Venezuela repatriará a un grupo de
migrantes varados en la frontera entre
chile y Perú para el canciller se trata
de un gran paso para enfrentar el
problema que ha generado tensiones entre
lima y Santiago Tenemos reporte
condenan a cuatro miembros de la
Organización de extrema derecha proud
Boys la justicia estadounidense los
encontró culpables de Conspiración
sediciosa para atacar el Capitolio el 6
de enero de 2021 en un intento por
mantener a Donald Trump en el poder
y el cantante británico Ed sheeran fue
exculpado de posible plagio tras el
fallo a su favor de un Jurado
estadounidense se le acusaba de posible
copia en la melodía en su tema thinking
outloud sheeran afirmó que la decisión
ayudará a proteger el proceso creativo
de cantautores en todo el mundo
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el Informativo
en Chile porque el canciller Alberto
banclabren confirmó que un avión
venezolano llegará en la madrugada del
domingo a arica en el norte del país
para repatriar a un grupo de migrantes
venezolanos varados desde hace varios
días entre las fronteras de chile y Perú
también otro grupo que se encuentra en
Perú viajará a su país de origen en este
avión nuestra corresponsal en Santiago
Patricia Luna nos amplía el canciller
chileno Alberto anclaren confirmó este
jueves la información que ya había sido
avanzada por la quincillería peruana de
que un avión venezolano viajará el
domingo hasta la frontera entre chile y
Perú para repatriar a los ciudadanos
venezolanos que han expresado su
voluntad de retornar a su país es un
avance para tratar de frenar esta crisis
humanitaria señaló el canciller que
afirmó que el abordaje ha de ser
regional puesto que son varios países
hasta los que están implicados y por lo
tanto la solución ha de ser una solución
conjunta el canciller afirmó que el
vuelo llegará en la madrugada del
domingo a la frontera entre chile y Perú
para llevarse a los ciudadanos
venezolanos que se encuentran ahí
también a un grupo que se encuentra en
la región chilena de arica y a un
pequeño grupo que se encuentra en Perú
todos ellos han sido empadronados y se
les han tomado los datos por parte del
personal del Consulado venezolano para
asegurarse de que no hay órdenes de
arraigo u otro tipo de órdenes y que por
lo tanto pueden salir del país es un
avión que será financiado completamente
por Venezuela confirmó también el
canciller de esta forma se trata de dar
salida a esta crisis humanitaria que
desde hace varias semanas tiene a varios
centenares de personas atrapados en la
frontera entre chile y Perú que no
pueden atravesar por no contar con la
documentación que se exige Para pasar al
otro país y también en una situación es
bastante extremas las que marca el
desierto de atacama que es el desierto
más seco del mundo
en Estados Unidos un tribunal condenó a
cuatro miembros del grupo de extrema
derecha proud Boys la Justicia del país
los halló culpables de Conspiración
sediciosa por organizar y participar en
el asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal basket no se emplea
enriquetario y los otros líderes de los
Boys
y real podrán pagar hasta 20 años de
cárcel tras ser declarados culpables de
los delitos de Conspiración sediciosa
conspiración para obstruir una sesión en
el congreso y obstrucción de
procedimiento durante casi 15 semanas
los fiscales alegaron que los Boys
enjuiciados se veían a sí mismos como el
ejército de Trump y buscaban mantener a
Trump en el poder a través de la
violencia el día en que el congreso se
reunió para certificar los resultados de
las elecciones presidenciales que
confirmaron a biden como presidente
enriquetario quien no testificó en el
juicio contradijo el argumento de su
equipo de defensa ante el Jurado de que
lo estaban convirtiendo en un chivo
expiatorio para Trump y quienes están en
el poder en cambio aceptó las
afirmaciones de Los partidarios de la
línea dura de Trump de que estaba siendo
utilizado como el próximo peldaño para
poder a Donald Trump quien quiere
reelegir si el resultado marcó la
tercera Victoria decisiva para el
departamento de justicia en tres juicios
por conspiración sediciosa llevados a
cabo después de lo que calificó como un
acto histórico y se ha calificado como
un acto histórico
doméstico de terrorismo por parte de los
demócratas y de la justicia
estadounidense y el senador de ver
Montes Bernie Sanders quien compitió con
Joe biden en las primarias demócratas y
hoy es presidente del comité de Salud
Educación trabajo y pensiones planea
presentar un proyecto de ley para subir
el salario mínimo argumentando que las
ganancias corporativas se están
disparando se espera que entre el 14 de
junio para después llevarlo al pleno
nadie en este país puede sobrevivir con
7,25 dólares la hora y tal vez algunos
de mis colegas En el congreso quieran
vivir un mes con 7 dólares y 25 centavos
la hora y ver que se siente no pueden
hacerlo con nueve dólares la hora no
puedes hacerlo con 12 dólares la hora
necesitamos una economía en la que todos
nuestros trabajadores ganen un salario
digno no es aceptable hoy que casi 35
millones de trabajadores estadounidenses
ganen menos de 17 dólares por hora
nos vamos hasta México en donde
descendieron las cifras de desempleo en
el tercer mes del año correspondió al
2,4% de la población económicamente
activa según el Instituto Nacional de
estadística un dato menor al 2,7% de
febrero y al del 3% de un año antes sin
embargo esta estadística mexicana
siempre se ve empañada por su tasa de
informalidad que hoy es del 55% y afecta
más de 33 millones de ciudadanos también
por la brecha laboral de género pues
menos de la mitad de las mujeres en edad
de trabajar tienen un empleo mientras
que en el caso de los hombres la
proporción es de casi un 80%
y las Naciones Unidas confirmaron que
acordaron con el gobierno hondureño el
envío de un grupo de expertos para
establecer una comisión internacional
contra la corrupción y la impunidad la
instalación de esta comisión había sido
una de las promesas de campaña del
actual presidente
Xiomara Castro el canciller del país
Eduardo Enrique reina calificó el
anuncio como una gran noticia para el
país y que A falta de acordar las fechas
para iniciar el proceso la misión no se
detendrá
continúa la visita de estado del
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro en
España Este martes sostuvo una reunión
en el Palacio de la moncloa con el jefe
del gobierno español Pedro Sánchez este
ha expresado su pleno apoyo al proyecto
de paz total de Gustavo Petro Sánchez
recordó que su país tiene el estatuto de
acompañante en el diálogo con el eln
pero evito comprometerse a mediar para
que la guerrilla salga de las listas de
organizaciones terroristas de los países
europeos tal y como pidió el presidente
colombiano
un método diferente quizás más real con
la realidades actuales de los grupos de
la violencia Pues nos ayude a que pueda
si las cosas van bien salir de
de las listas de terroristas que se
elaboran por los países
y adquirir otro estatus realmente
político en función de cual sea El
Avance en ese proceso de negociación y
de diálogo Pues evidentemente nosotros a
disposición del presidente y del
gobierno colombiano para hablar con el
resto de socios europeos y efectivamente
pues materializar esas peticiones que
haga el presidente Petro y el gobierno
colombiano y un Jurado estadounidense
concluyó que el cantante británico Ed
sheeran no plagió el éxito musical
letzgerón del cantautor Marvin gaye Los
herederos de eptown Send también
cantante y Quien escribió la canción de
los 70 en los 70 habían demandado a
siran en 2017 por infracción de derechos
de autor alegando que su hit thinking
outloud copió la melodía la armonía y el
ritmo de la canción de Calle hablamos
anteriormente con el abogado y asesor
legal de proyectos culturales en temas
de propiedad intelectual Santiago San
Miguel que nos respondía sobre si hoy en
día los artistas Tiene las manos atadas
a la hora de crear por temor a posibles
demandas de este tipo
no yo creo que no las tienen atadas de
ninguna manera las tienen atadas Qué
sucede Y es que hay una cosa que es
demandar y otra cosa es ganarse las
demandas y son cosas diferentes creo que
Ed sheeran le han caído varios que
simplemente quieren demandar y No
necesariamente tienen los argumentos
para ganarse las demandas lo que pasa
con el que ellos ya habían ganado una
demanda del 2015 contra farrel eh
Williams por pues la canción de
digamos que tenían como ganas de seguir
explorando estos estos asuntos qué pasa
y es yo no creo que tenga las manos
atadas los cantautores y los
compositores y demás Pueden seguir
tranquilos que siempre y cuando ellos o
ellas estén haciendo las canciones ellos
mismos pues las cosas van a salir bien
que si están tomando de los otros claro
ahí hay que preocuparse pero pero
siempre que estén componiendo de su
propia inspiración y su propio trabajo
lo más probable es que lo estén haciendo
bien
hasta aquí este informativo sigan
conectados a France 24 y Recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda esta y mucha más
información en nuestro sitio web Flash
24.com
[Música]